on poursuit notre série sur les
nouvelles pratiques agricoles plus
économes en eau le plan haut du
gouvernement présentait le 30 mars
dernier prévoit d'augmenter la
réutilisation des eaux usées traitées de
1 à 10% d'ici 2030 l'agriculture en est
l'un des débouchés exemple à osware dans
cette commune d'Indre-et-Loire deux
agriculteurs pionniers dans le pionniers
dans le département utilisent
gratuitement l'eau de la station
d'épuration de Château-Renault pas assez
propre pour être entièrement rejeté dans
les cours d'eau elle est en revanche
adaptée aux cultures reportages de
Florent Clavel
[Musique]
claire comme de l'eau de station
d'épuration
ce matin Damien des nœuds inspecte ses
maïs 13 ans maintenant que cet
agriculteur utilise l'eau épurée de la
station voisine de Château-Renault non
potable elle n'en revanche que des
bienfaits pour les cultures comme c'est
de l'eau épurée c'est vrai qu'il y a une
légère odeur et
ça ça arrive quand c'est le début de la
saison elle apporte un petit peu d'azote
mais vraiment très légère et surtout
depuis qu'on utilise cette eau là on n'a
pas besoin de rapporter de potasses
sur la sur la culture
l'agriculteur d'osuère en Touraine est
un pionnier
l'histoire démarre en 1998 une nouvelle
station d'épuration doit avoir le jour à
Château-Renault problème avec les
nouvelles réglementations
environnementales plus question de
diluer la totalité des rejets dans la
Brenne
c'est donc Damien et son voisin Olivier
agriculteur lui aussi qui vont
l'utiliser une retenue de 50000 mètres
cubes et construite des arroseurs des
tuyaux et des pompes installés pour
acheminer l'eau pour un coup de 28000
euros seulement pour chaque agriculteur
grâce au subventions pour nous ça a été
une opportunité parce que c'est le fait
de sécuriser nos cultures de la
sécheresse donc ça nous permet de
d'irriguer du blé un peu ou des maïs
surtout et là on réutilise de l'eau
c'est un partenariat gagnant-gagnant
avec la collectivité et nous qui
utilisons et quelque part dépollons le
milieu aquatique une eau qui plus est
gratuite pour les deux agriculteurs il
pèsent seulement l'électricité et les
arroseurs